before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
what is the doctor without the right
companion
[Music]
and here's me thinking we were done with
Doctor Who announcements for a little
while apologies if I seem a little bit
low energy uh I'm actually getting over
cold it's been kind of rough the last
couple days it's not coveted but you
know still anyways uh we now know who's
going to be playing the companion to
shoot doctor after the David Tennant
specials happen this was revealed at
children in need and the reveal was
actress Millie Gibson who I know pretty
much nothing about I mean I know what I
looked up on Wikipedia she's been on
Coronation Street which is a soap opera
in the UK for quite a while and she has
actually gotten awards for her
performances there and that's certainly
not a bad sign at all
honestly what might be the funniest
thing to me was seeing uh so many people
on Twitter including like a number of
sort of YouTubers who I know sort of
freaking out that the uh that the new
companion is so much younger than them
it's like dudes I've been dealing with
companions younger than me since Amy
Pond welcome to the freaking club
anyways
um so I don't have a lot to go off of in
terms of knowing her previous
performances it's kind of the same with
shittigatwa I kind of have to go buy
what I see
um from just a general presence in the
little bits that we now have and she
seems energetic she seems very excited
to be there there was uh also sort of a
little interview thing done between
shurigatwa and her where he asked her a
number of questions they had some banter
they seemed to have like just good
direct chemistry they bounced off each
other really well they seem both very
happy to be there and to hear gospel say
it he personally was so impressed with
her audition that as soon as you left
the room for your audition I was like
Russell that is the companion
just magic magic now that doesn't
necessarily mean it was got was called
but he is saying that she was the one
that he felt was going to best embody
the character we do also have a
character name that being Ruby Sunday
which tells us nothing and I don't have
an opinion on uh somebody at some point
is going to make a Ruby Tuesday joke
they're like that's that that has to
happen now not that I'm saying it'd be a
good thing that I haven't but like
that's I I'd be shocked if it doesn't
but other than that there isn't a heck
of a lot to go on we don't know uh where
Ruby is coming from in terms of either
where she lives presumably somewhere in
the UK
um or what point in time she comes from
uh however this is where I'm gonna get a
little bit speculative because even
though things like the interview between
shurigatwa and Millie Gibson looked
largely unscripted it was still edited
the things that were included and
allowed to go public are things that
have basically been approved and be like
yes that's fine to know and Russell uh
Russell T Davis current showrunner has
been kind of Notorious being very
careful
um in terms of what he allows to get out
there and get hinted at
um including outright lying at times but
I'm going to get speculative because
that's kind of all I have to go off of
we don't know enough about the character
for me to actually have a heck of a big
opinion I'm also not presuming that
that's what she's going to be wearing
actually as the companion I don't
presume that that's a costume that she's
going to be wearing same with the things
that we are currently seeing shurigatwa
in so I don't think we've had costume
reveals I think those will come later
so the things I'm going to get
speculative about mainly have to do with
what I can guess based off things that
have been said either in this little
interview or by Joshua before when he
did a little thing and that went up out
of like a month or two ago I can't I
can't remember now but
um what he said there that some people
kind of jumped on and I chose to ignore
at the time is that when he described to
the companion he specifically said human
Doctor Who is a show about an alien Time
Lord with two hearts who travels through
time and space with a human companion by
the side in the Tardis which
I had always kind of Presumed like one
of the things I've been complaining
about with modern era Doctor Who is the
companions
um they have a tendency to be
pretty samey I mean there are exceptions
here and there but by and large
young women from the UK modern era
um we had a chance to break from that if
Clara had been kept as the governess
version of her from the snowmen which I
actually would have liked I would I
really liked that version of Clara but
we didn't get that and we've had some
some exceptions here and there Donna
being a little bit older
um you know the fam with uh Jody
Whitaker you had Ryan and UA Graham uh
initially and then later on Dan who kind
of shook things up we had Rory back with
Amy but like the core companion the main
companion
has generally fit this mold and it would
appear that Millie is likely to do the
same as well now you go back to Classic
era Doctor Who
companions could be from anywhere there
were companions from other planets the
future the past other time Lords it was
such a wide variety now most of them
were human and a good chunk of them were
from the modern era but it wasn't every
time and some of my favorite companions
break that I love Jamie McCrimmon him
and the second doctor are amazing and
he's from a further point in history
plus you know a dude and it's just such
a different Dynamic from almost any
other doctor and companion pairing and
it's great the fourth doctor in Romana
especially the second version of Romana
Lala Ward were also great together
though I I like original Ramana as well
but again from a completely different
point in time Nissa adric so many people
from all over the place but here like
all the time
modern day that's kind of the big thing
like I'm willing to let go of them being
human but
why are they always from the
contemporaneous era
are are we really still at a point where
we think we need that window into the
doctor that if we don't have a modern
era person's perspective we won't get
what's going on
unfortunately I think the show might
actually think that and by the show I
mean the people currently involved in it
because in the little interviewee thing
with shurigatwa Millie Gibson says flat
out well they are the eyes into your
world and they are the audience eyes to
see what will happen in your universe
and I'm not gonna say that's wrong I
have said in the past that I think a
good strong core relationship between
the doctor and the companion is a lot of
insight into the doctor is and it's a
way that I frequently understand them
but again
speaking only for myself I don't need
the companion to bear that much of
resemblance to me directly it's just the
nature of the dynamic that's going to
tell me a lot again I'll point to
something like the second doctor and
Jamie as being a really great example of
how their Dynamic told a lot about them
but Jaime's perspective was not a modern
day perspective he was from way in the
past
so
the idea that they need to be from now
still frustrates me and at this point I
am just assuming that that's going to be
the case because while at present
unconfirmed and it is possible I'm wrong
about this but just to hear them talk
about it I'm just getting that
impression all over again and that is
frustrating for me because it's
it's
getting old
and I know that to a certain extent each
new era is kind of treated as a little
bit of a soft reboot and a chance for
new people to come in and maybe there's
a certain amount of pressure either from
the BBC or just internally with the
creative team to be like we need to be
sure that this is accessible to new
people
so like I maybe I kind of get it from
that perspective except that there's
also a heck of a lot of old fans
especially with you bringing Russell T
Davis back to run the show again you're
going to be getting back a lot of people
who know the deal who don't mean the
Modern Eyes
another reason that I think that modern
era Doctor Who has a tendency to lean
very heavily on this is
um frankly as a form of budget control
because if you have a contemporaneous
modern era companion that gives you a
lot more reason to have a lot more
stories set in the here and now which
can just be shot on available locations
you don't have to build elaborate sets
you don't have to use a ton of CGI now
how much of an impact that is for the
particular upcoming series it's hard to
say because we've now got Disney
involved did a whole video on that and
while Disney does not suddenly own
doctor who they are contributing some of
the funds to the production doctor who
has more money to play with
so while I think that has been part of
the consideration in the past for why
companions are from modern era that
shouldn't necessarily need to be one
going forward
I mean I suppose it depends on what the
money gets allocated to maybe it's
intended much more for promotional
purposes than anything else who knows
but
it just
it makes me it's the first thing
honestly to kind of make me nervous
about this upcoming era
um it's also a little bit of a
disappointment because I had kind of
hoped that Yasmine Finney would carry
over from the specials that David
Tennant's going to be in now we don't
know a ton about her character either
but I had kind of hoped seemed like it
would have been a really neat idea and
so now I know that's not happening I
mean you know maybe she wasn't available
for more than the specials there could
be all kinds of mitigating circumstances
as to why she's not staying on
um at least by any indication that we
currently have and certainly not as the
primary companion but you know part of
me had hoped
but I frequently have my hopes dashed on
that when it was revealed that Graham
and Ryan were both leaving and Yaz was
staying on for uh the series 13 AKA flux
I got excited because I wanted to see
that relationship develop not in a
shipping way I don't actually care too
much about the shipping but just in
terms of building a stronger Dynamic and
then they announced another additional
companion when they brought in Dan and I
didn't dislike them when he showed up
but
it just became another thing where I'm
like you you
you had the opportunity to do something
that or that I would have liked to have
seen and you just didn't you just didn't
do it so I'm feeling a little bit the
same way about not keeping Yasmine
Finney on partially because like it's
been a while we haven't we've only had
in the modern era two companions carry
over and stick around from one
regeneration to the next Rose Tyler and
Clara Oswalt that's it all the rest have
been contained within a single era and I
think it would have been a decent time
to sort of revive that and have someone
you know if if Yaz as a character you
know mandip Gill wasn't going to stick
around then possibly to have Yasmin
Finney accompany David Tennant's 14th
doctor I guess we're still going with
that
um through whatever's going on there and
then just stick around after that I mean
just doing the carryover that's a
dynamic that hasn't been done all that
much and I think if we're going to be
stuck with so much other stuff that is
very standard at this point such as a
young woman from contemporary England
then you know doing something to shake
it up a little so it's not checking all
the same boxes would have been nice
again this is speculative on my part
it's possible that I could end up being
wrong about some of this I kind of hope
that I am
but I don't really have a firm belief
behind that it is just hope
I don't have a reason to believe that
she won't be from modern era and
I just could we
could we stop can we take a break from
that like more than anything I used to
complain about it being
um young traditionally attractive women
as well I've kind of let that go
partially because we've had
um some shakeups from that you know we
had Donna being a bit older than the
others we've had Graham we've had Ryan
we've had Dan you know we've had some
Mix-Ups as far as that stuff goes but at
this point like it is the Contemporary
origin for the companion that has yet to
be broken
in this modern era not even once
come on
can we get a break from that
uh and no like one-off companions from
specials don't count I'm talking about
primary sustained companions
oh well
I don't know
I don't know
um I'm sure she'll be fine in the part I
don't doubt that I'm sure she did in
fact kill it in the um in the audition
and like I said she's got just really
good presence in chemistry with
shurikatua so like I'm not worried about
their Dynamic I'm sure she'll be fine
it's just that on paper what I am fairly
confident saying she's likely to be is
just something I'm less interested in
doesn't mean I can't turn around on it
but it does mean that
um the concept isn't exciting for me so
the performances and the stories that
are being uh told with these characters
I really kind of need to be quite good
because your basic premise or at least
what I am presuming to be your basic
premise doesn't super excite me
but it's it's early I expect the next
thing we'll probably get is uh is an
outfit reveal although I'm expecting
that some months down the line probably
not until they start shooting uh
whatever ends up being gotcha's first
series
um which will probably start shooting in
the next few months and then there will
well either it'll just leak or they'll
try and get ahead of that and and do
like a a formal reveal of the outfit
like was done with some of the past
doctors it was done with Whitaker it was
done uh with Capaldi so like maybe we'll
get that that's kind of what I'm
expecting uh to be the next thing and
then
um you know probably a few months after
that some ramp UPS on things like
trailers for the tenant specials that's
kind of what I'm presuming is coming
down the line but you know I don't know
maybe they'll throw some more curveballs
at me I'm not expecting I'll have to
turn something around fairly quickly
like I did with this just by getting
over a cold what are your thoughts on
any of this
um on the casting on my concerns
whatever whatever they are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it patreon's what pays the
bills around here and allows me to do
this as my living like share subscribe
are also a huge help but even if you
can't
what I really want you to remember is
that you are beautiful
you are valid and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
and credits that means I need to shout
out my top Patron supporters Robin Moore
zupin but foa to rock the thing that
goes joint in the anime Oliver B Linda
Walters emu Delhi leotha Boyd toy lowly
Becky Sparks bernabe likes the poodle
Zach Tracy scrabot angry Casper Adam RDL
Taylor Shea lugurley Brendan Larose and
TT
thank you so much for your support you
can get your name in the credits too by
checking out the rewards on the patreon
you only try deep my earring once this
time that's much better
[Music]